Despite the satisfying way "F9" continues
the stories of Dom, Letty, and all the rest,
there are a number of questions we've been
left to ponder since the credits rolled.
Here are some of the biggest.
The newest — and wildest — adventure in
the "Fast and Furious" saga is kicked off
when Mr. Nobody sends an encrypted distress
signal meant only for Vin Diesel’s character,
Dom Toretto, and his team.
In his message, he says his plane is going
down with dangerous cargo on board.
Ramsey is the one who picks it up, and wastes
no time in getting most of the team back together.
After some light persuasion, she and Dom,
along with Letty, Roman, and Tej are on board.
At the crash site, however, there's no trace
of Mr. Nobody.
After doing a cursory sweep for him and coming
up empty, Dom's crew never seems to spend
any more energy trying to figure out if he's
still alive.
Sure, it looked like a pretty devastating
crash, but considering Mr. Nobody’s apparent
ability to arrange the impossible, it seems
as though nothing is beyond his grasp.
Speaking of Mr. Nobody and the impossible,
Han is apparently alive in "F9," despite the
seemingly deadly crash and murder attempt
in "Tokyo Drift."
The same scene which we saw revisited again
in "Fast & Furious 6" and "Furious 7" — except
the explanation doesn't actually account for
what happened.
According to Han, he was recruited as an operative
by Mr. Nobody.
Apparently, this happened sometime between
the end of "Fast & Furious 6" and the beginning
of "Tokyo Drift" which chronologically takes
place between the sixth and seventh films.
Sometime before Sean Boswell showed up in
Tokyo, Han did a job for Mr. Nobody that required
him to stay hidden.
Mr. Nobody, then, determined the best way
to do this was to fake Han's death, so no
one would be looking for him.
It's a neat workaround for bringing back the
character, except for one thing: the car chase
Han was involved in when he "died" was completely
impromptu.
In "Tokyo Drift," we see that Han is fleeing
his former business partner after he got caught
stealing.
Previously, it seemed as though Deckard Shaw
took advantage of that opportunity to take
Han out by T-boning him with his own car.
But now we are to understand that Mr. Nobody
somehow staged the entire thing.
Since we definitely saw that Han was physically
present for the entire chase in "Tokyo Drift,"
even seeing the crash from inside his car,
there's no way he could have somehow escaped
the car before Deckard crashed into him.
Was Mr. Nobody lurking around, ready to extract
him the instant an opportunity presented itself?
If so, how did he get Han out of the wrecked
car without anyone noticing?
"F9" gives us some answers, but really only
raises more questions.
While Mr. Nobody's presence looms large over
the plot of "F9," even if he isn't physically
around, his protege is nowhere to be found,
and isn't even mentioned.
Introduced in "Fate of the Furious," Little
Nobody, who’s played by Scott Eastwood,
worked alongside the rest of the crew in thwarting
their enemy, Cipher.
Little Nobody was at the family barbecue at
the end of the film, which is typically a
pretty solid indicator that a character has
ascended to the rank of "family" and will
continue to pop up in future installments.
Even still, he's completely absent in "F9."
Now, it’s not a stretch to say that Little
Nobody didn't make much of an impression in
"Fate of the Furious."
Unlike most of the other recurring "Fast and
Furious" characters, who each have personality
by the bucketful, he was by nature pretty
bland and didn't add much to the crew.
Granted, this was partially because he was
a covert government agent who was supposed
to be able to disappear, but even Mr. Nobody
managed to live under the radar while still
being an engaging character.
So perhaps he was left out simply because
he wouldn't be particularly missed.
Still, it's a little odd that with a plot
that so heavily ties into Mr. Nobody's plans,
no one would even think to mention looking
for his second in command.
"F9" actually does a good job of explaining
why Dom and Mia have never mentioned they
had another brother before, and have erased
him from all their childhood stories.
It turns out that in the race that killed
Dom's father, which he told Brian about in
the first movie, his car had been tampered
with, causing it to respond poorly during
the race.
Teenage Dom realized it was his younger brother
Jakob who had messed with the car, and assumed
he'd sabotaged their father on purpose.
Dom banished Jakob from the family, and never
spoke of him again.
However, it’s later revealed that Jakob
stayed with a friend of their dad’s named
Buddy nearby for about a year before moving
on.
This is a little odd, seeing that Dom or Mia
would have possibly crossed paths with Jakob
again after he left the Toretto home.
After all, Buddy seemed pretty close to the
Toretto family.
Did Jakob have to leave the house and pretend
that he wasn't living there if Dom or Mia
pass by Buddy's house?
That seems to be the only way they could've
avoided running into one another and triggering
an extremely awkward conversation.
Dom says in the film that he knew Jakob was
living with Buddy, so maybe the elder Toretto
just avoided Buddy for a while.
Dom soon realizes that the person responsible
for stealing the device capable of hijacking
every superweapon in the world is his estranged
brother Jakob, played by John Cena.
So, Dom sets off to track down his long-lost
sibling.
First, he visits Buddy and learns Jakob has
gone to London.
Then, he heads to London, where he asks Magdalene
Shaw what she can find out through her underworld
connections.
Sure enough, she knows right where he can
find Jakob, and drives him right to his brother's
doorstep.
But while Dom's detective work is impressive,
it also raises some questions.
First of all, how did he even know where to
find Magdalene Shaw?
More importantly, why did he have to do all
this tracking in the first place when he could've
just used the God's Eye?
First introduced in "Furious 7," the God's
Eye is a piece of tracking software that can
be used to find anyone on the planet in seconds.
The crew used it again in "Fate of the Furious"
to track down Cipher.
Plus, Dom has the inventor of the God's Eye,
Ramsey, on his crew.
So why the pond-hopping when Dom could've
cut straight to the chase?
Did they simply forget they had the world's
most advanced tracking technology at their
disposal?
So let's address the elephant in the room
right away: there are a lot of issues with
Roman and Tej’s space plan.
“Please tell me that’s not a Pontiac Fiero
strapped to a rocket engine.”
Most of these issues we're willing to let
slide because this is a "Fast and Furious"
movie and realism has never been a major selling
point for this franchise.
However, it seems a little odd that after
defying all odds and managing to destroy the
satellite they were sent to disarm, they are
then able to essentially hitchhike home with
the astronauts aboard the International Space
Station without any negative consequences.
Granted, we don't actually have any clue what
would happen if two men in scuba suits wound
up floating by in a Pontiac Fiero outside
the International Space Station.
Hardly seems like the sort of thing anyone
would plan for.
But it does seem like it should be more severe
than just eating Tootsie Rolls for a couple
weeks and then being allowed to tag along
on their trip back to Earth.
While it's possible Roman and Tej escaped
on a technicality, considering the possibility
that there aren't actually any laws governing
what they did, the same can't be said for
everyone else.
Dom and his crew caused a massive destruction
while working to stop Otto from gaining the
power to destroy the world.
This isn't the first time Dom's crew has leveled
several city blocks or destroyed dozens of
cars.
However, in previous films, they either had
to go on the run afterward or were working
for the government, which presumably helped
clean up the mess.
This time, they're effectively on their own.
This raises the question of why they're able
to relax at a family barbecue at the end instead
of being arrested for causing tens of millions
of dollars worth of property damage.
Not even including all the cars they destroy,
they also take out multiple buildings with
their magnetic shenanigans.
It seems a little weird that no one needs
to pay — literally — for all the destruction
they caused, even if it happened in the name
of saving the world.
“No one needs to know about this.”
Once again, just like at the end of "Fate
of the Furious," Cipher manages to evade capture
at the end of "F9," even though the rest of
the team she's working with isn't nearly so
lucky.
Of course, sometime between the ending of
"Fate of the Furious" and the beginning of
"F9," Mr. Nobody somehow managed to track
her down and capture her, so we know that
such a thing is possible.
But at the same time, he didn't manage to
hold on to her for long.
Plus, we have no idea where Mr. Nobody even
is anymore, or how to get a hold of his covert
organization.
And we definitely expect Cipher to be even
more careful this time about covering her
tracks.
So it seems like the odds of her being found
before she wants to are low, and that whenever
she does reappear, it will be in a fittingly
dramatic and shocking fashion.
"F9" made an impressive effort to bring back
all sorts of familiar faces from previous
films.
Even Brian was implied to be present at the
final barbecue, although we only got to see
his car.
But one former member of the team was noticeably
absent: Luke Hobbs, played by Dwayne Johnson,
who's been an integral member of the crew
since "Fast Five."
Behind the scenes, Johnson is busy with his
own spinoff franchise, "Hobbs and Shaw," as
well as numerous other projects.
But just because the actor wasn't available
doesn't mean we aren't wondering where the
character is.
It seems that given the high stakes and difficult
nature of their mission, it would've made
sense to call in the big guns.
But Hobbs isn't even mentioned in "F9," making
us wonder why the characters wouldn't have
thought to call him.
Perhaps they already knew he wouldn't be available;
maybe he's spending more time with his daughter,
or visiting his family in Samoa, whom he reconnected
with in "Hobbs and Shaw.”
“Daddy’s staying home.”
There are any number of places he could have
been, but it feels a little weird that the
movie doesn't even hint at where he was.
Early in "F9," after surviving several situations
that should've reasonably resulted in his
death, Roman postulates that perhaps the reason
he keeps defying death is because he and the
rest of the crew are actually invincible.
And while Tej and Ramsey laugh at Roman's
outlandish theory, by the end of "F9," we're
kind of wondering if he might be onto something.
After all, Letty and Han survived crashes
that everyone assumed killed them.
Roman and Tej manage to survive a trip to
outer space in a car that exploded earlier
in the movie.
Not to mention countless close-calls for every
member of the crew throughout the franchise.
Of course, there is one person who throws
a wrench in this theory: Gisele, who died
at the end of "Fast & Furious 6" saving Han.
If one member of their crew died, it stands
to reason that all of them could under the
right circumstances — unless, of course,
Gisele is somehow still alive too.
While we're not holding our breath, after
getting #JusticeForHan, we won't rule anything
out.
And if Gisele ever does return to the family,
there really may be something to Roman's bizarre
theory after all.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.